webassembly opens the door to building
high performance applications on the web
in languages other than javascript
in today's video we'll build a simple
video editing tool that can take a video
file
and convert it to an animated gif the
cool thing about this demo is that it's
made possible by a library called ffmpeg
which is a utility written in the c
programming language but thanks to
webassembly we can run this tool
directly in the browser
and that means we can perform cpu
intensive video editing jobs without the
need for a backend server
for example here's how a traditional web
application might work we collect a
video file from the end user
then upload it to the cloud we use our
cloud server to run ffmpeg to encode the
file
and send it back down to the client that
works fine but it's not very efficient
and it also has no way to work offline
if you're building a progressive web app
what we'll do in this video is download
the webassembly binary for
ffmpeg directly into a react app
allowing us to combine the c programming
language with javascript
and offload the video editing work to
the end user's hardware
if you're new here like and subscribe
and follow along with the full write up
and source code on fireship io and if
you have no idea what webassembly is
check out my 100 second breakdown on
that topic this tutorial is very
beginner friendly
and doesn't require that you know
anything about the c programming
language
that's because the ffmpeg.wasm package
provides an api in javascript to
interact with this low-level utility
now before we jump into the code let's
take a closer look at the demo we have a
file input where we can select a video
file
the video can be previewed in a video
element then when you click the convert
button
it runs ffmpeg to load the video file
into memory
and run the conversion very simple stuff
but my main goal here is to give you a
starting point for building more complex
features through the magic of
webassembly
to get things started i'm generating a
new react app using snowpack
and keep in mind here the code is very
simple so feel free to follow along with
any other framework
then from inside your project you'll
want to install the following packages
from the ffmpeg namespace and lastly you
can run npm start which should give you
the default react app running in the
browser
from there we'll go into the source
directory and open the app.js file
i'm going to go ahead and delete all the
boilerplate code leaving us with a basic
starting point
from there i'm going to import two
functions from the ffmpeg namespace
the first function create ffmpeg we can
call right away
which gives us a starting point for
working with this library we'll set the
log option to true
so we can see everything that it does
directly in the console now it's
important to understand at this point
that the actual webassembly binary has
not been bundled in our application
it's a pretty large file so we don't
want it to block our web application
right away
instead we load it asynchronously over a
cdn to keep track of the loading state
i'll go ahead and add a stateful
property here called ready with the use
state hook
it has a default value of false and then
we'll create an async function here
called
load that can flip it to true after the
binary has been loaded
the function awaits the ffmpeg load
promise
and once loaded we can flip the ready
state to true and now we just need a
place to call this function
in react we can do that with the use
effect hook to run this function when
the component is first initialized use
effect takes a function as its argument
then notice how i'm adding an empty
array as the second argument
this will ensure that the function is
only called once when the component is
first initialized or mounted
then inside the effect we can simply
call our load function
if you go ahead and save the file and
open up the browser you should get a
blank page
but in the console you'll notice that
ffmpeg core is being loaded in the
background
in fact if we go over to the sources tab
you can inspect the actual webassembly
code there
you don't need to understand what any of
this code means but it is useful to know
that this originally started as the c
programming language
and then was compiled over to
webassembly what we're looking at here
is the webassembly text
which is an intermediate format before
it becomes binary or ones and zeros
now back in the source code we'll go
into our jsx and then we'll use the
ternary operator with our ready state
if the app's ready we'll show the main
ui otherwise we'll just show the text of
loading
now our next challenge is loading a
video file into the application
and also showing it in a video player in
the ui the first step
is to add additional state to the
component in this case a video file
which will initially start undefined in
the html
we can add an input element with a type
of file when this input changes
we'll run an event handler that will set
the video state
and it gets the actual file from the
event the event emits a file list
and then we use item 0 to select the
first file from that list
now that we have access to a video file
we want to display it in an html video
element
we'll use a logical and operator to only
show the video when the video file is
defined
the element has controls a width of 250
but a tricky thing here is that we can't
just pass the raw file to the source
attribute
we need to convert it to a url that the
browser can fetch
we can handle that by using the url
interface and then calling its create
object url method
which takes the file object as its
argument if we go ahead and open up the
demo we should now be able to choose a
file on our system
and then have that file displayed in the
video player and now we're ready for the
fun part
using ffmpeg and webassembly to modify
this video file
or in our case convert the file to an
animated gif the first thing we'll do
here
is add one more piece of state to the
component called gif and it will be used
to hold the end result which is a url of
an image file
from there we'll create a function
called convert to gif which the user can
run when they're ready to make the
conversion
now one thing to understand here is that
webassembly is managing its own
in-memory file system and in order to
run ffmpeg on that file we need to make
it known to that file system
we can do that by calling fs or file
system
along with the write file method along
with the name of the file
and then we fetch the actual video file
that we've collected from the end user
what we've done is taken the video file
and saved it to a place in memory
as test.mp4 it can be now accessed by
webassembly while it's in memory
and it only stays in memory until the
browser is refreshed
from there we can run an actual ffmpeg
command if you're not familiar with this
utility
it's a command line tool that can
perform all kinds of video editing jobs
it's been around for a very long time
and you can check out the full
documentation to get an idea of what it
can do
we can run the command by simply passing
arguments that we would normally pass to
the command line
the i flag is for the input file the t
flag
is for the time that we want the length
of the video to be we can offset
it with starting seconds then we use the
flag to encode it as a gif file
when that's complete it will write the
result to memory and then we can access
it
by again using the file system command
this time to read a file called
out.gif we then need to convert the file
data into a url that can be used in the
browser
once again we'll use url create object
url
and as its argument will create a new
blob blob is kind of a scary word
but it just means a raw file which in
this case is the binary that we can
access from the data buffer
it's also a good idea to pass a second
argument with the mime type of the
object which in this case is a gif
image and lastly we take that url and
update the state of the component
from there we just have a couple of
simple updates to make to the ui
we'll go down here and add a button that
when clicked we'll run the convert to
gif function
and then we'll add an image tag that's
only displayed when we have the gif url
you should now be able to open up your
demo select a video file
then when you click the convert button
it uses webassembly to convert that file
to an animated gif
and it should log the entire process
here in the console you could then take
this file and upload it to giphy
or use it on twitter or whatever you
want and that's how easy it is to start
incorporating webassembly into your web
applications
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there but in the near future i plan on
making a video about how to take your
own custom rust code
and convert it to webassembly to be used
in the browser and if you have any ideas
please let me know in the comments
if you want to learn more and support my
work consider becoming a pro member at
fireship io
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one
you